hey guys I think so for the next 24
hours I will only be eating foods that
are at the color purple a lot of people
have been doing this on YouTube it's a
very popular format that I also wanted
to try for myself to not just experiment
it's also just a cool way for you guys
to find out what there is out there
that's edible and is purple so I think
purple because I wanted a little bit of
a challenge but not so much that I'd be
starving myself I'm actually going to
try and stay away from anything that's
artificially colored has to be naturally
colored purple which kind of just makes
my job harder than it already is
so the next step is to go to the grocery
store and see what we can find for
breakfast lunch and dinner that is
purple all right purple one so I'm gonna
keep
of course there's grapes if you like
fakes might be purple
here too blueberries savory foods I
think each are the first potato chef it
is black but it's actually purple fruit
juice that should be reported
there's this huge bag of just different
kinds of purple things now it's a planet
my meals for tomorrow I made it back
home with my I also change into a purple
shirt I'm just going to take everything
out now to see what I have just to show
you guys what we're working with this is
everything I've bought from the store I
also have purple noodles I think are
made with like purple yam and then I
also have this indigo punch T this is
butterfly pea flower in it if we add
like lemon juice or lime juice will
become purple so I thought that would be
a good trip I think we have a good
balance of protein fruits vegetables and
carbs
I haven't really planned out my meals
yet but yeah so we have a lot of food
here and let's start it off with
breakfast this is my kitchen because
it's New York City it's pretty small but
I try to make this work I'm picking out
all of the fruits that I bought
blueberries grapes plums and fakes we
also already have this blue machine
smoothie that's actually purple but I
figured I could just make my own
so smoothie building time it's like
different shades of purple where's our
blender of these all and I'm gonna pour
some of the smoothie in there to that
purple just to amp it up I have my
blueberry jam super purple and now to
blitz it honey I think is this purple
under this light it looks a little bit
more purple so I think this is not
drinkable that custom food up it's just
really have you guys we have the plums
on top we have the grapes fake it's like
kind of wrinkly here that looks pretty
purple right I'm just gonna go ahead and
try this now to me it really just looks
like a normal like blueberry smoothie
Bowl so hmm
I guess you really couldn't make a
smoothie boat out of purely purple foods
I'll just be here finishing this then
I'll see you guys at work for lunch we
have catered lunch date
I'm gonna try and see if we can find
purple foods if I was purple hair I
can't find any purple foods I'm gonna
have to cook my own so let's see if we
can find some I don't see any that's red
[Music]
so because we couldn't find anything out
there I'm just going to try and make my
own lunch good thing I brought some
stuff with me this is what I have the
red onions carrots didn't really have
that many purple carrots but I tried to
pick some out and then I have the
octopus I know this is kind of
intimidating maybe for people who
haven't had it before
but it's actually really good and then
we have the purple yam noodles a nice
light purple I would say I didn't have a
sauce but because it came into the tasty
space I actually found this red wine
sauce that tasty producer Alvin was
making that is actually purple so I
guess we have a sauce now I'm just gonna
toss these in there and let it cook and
while that's cooking I'm just going to
cut some of this onion and the carrots
up noodles are now cooked kind of a
pinkish purple half the onions cut up
yeah carrots we have the octopus toss it
up and the purple carrots actually end
up having like orange bits in them
I think it's smelling pretty good so far
but onions I feel like just have a
stronger flavor than yellow or white
onions the octopus is actually already
cooked I just figured we'd give it a
little more flavor and add the noodles
in this is looking really purple I don't
really know what I was expecting but
this is pretty freakin awesome it's so
purple onions and carrots
that's our very purple looking and dish
this actually turned out to look a lot
better than I thought it was going to
differ excited to taste this but before
that a purple drink so this butterfly
pea flower
it's a flower that just turns liquid
into this
to a blue color I had my hotwire can you
see the color I didn't even need to add
lemon because I think this tea already
has some raspberry and apple bits in it
I guess I already have a purple drink
purple tea purple pasta it smells really
good so hopefully that means it actually
is really good Wow
I don't think I've ever had things that
are this vividly colored that isn't like
you know artificial wow that is actually
that's actually really good I think it's
because the sauce is really good I can't
believe we were actually able to make
this work I try this to youtube look at
this color I didn't even have to add
anything else to it this turned out so
good now I feel a little more confident
about dinner
I gotta get a second taste tester it's
so portable it was with your red wine
sauce if it looked purple then that
means I did it right it's gonna rain
right oh my god okay I'm about to take a
snack break
my kids have my tea here but Ashley is
giving me really weird looks I don't get
it but I
you always it's just a better client PC
from a diamond no it's not it's natural
I like it it's good it's a little
thicker
I'm very purple I'm on my way back home
it's still light outside but I'm really
hungry we're just gonna see what we can
make with the food we bought we have the
purple cabbage eggplant this is the
leftover onion red onion from lunch this
is really cool this is purple shiso leaf
so I got them from an event I went to
earlier they're green on the other side
but this side is purple there's also the
squid pretty purple looking I also just
love squid so this worked out perfectly
for me can you guys see how the water is
actually purple here's all the
vegetables I have just going to stir fry
it now I'm also just snacking on this
while I'm waiting I'm a big sweet potato
person normally so I think that's why
I'm really loving this I feel healthier
too a lot eating this even though it's
probably August in my head there's a lot
of sugar on this it looks healthier than
a normal potato chips can't forget the
black rice I know it's not black it
actually is purple I also just eat this
a lot normally this is the one I have at
home this is what just the black rice
looks like you could cook this as is too
but it would just be a little too coarse
when you mix it with white rice it looks
like this just gonna pop them in the
microwave this is what it kind of looks
like now thinking about putting it in
this onigiri mold I have
add the squid rings already cooked so
this is my purple dinner I know there's
a lot of white here this part is purple
probably as purple as it gets
without artificial dyes dinner is served
yeah I don't really know what I'm paid
but I think this looks pretty purple and
then I also had some of the tea left
over from earlier I just made that into
an iced version I don't normally cook
with eggplant it's like turned out kind
of brown this is a pretty purple
mouthful here's a squid I should show
you guys the purple side even though
there's no sauce to go with it I still
love it I love how chewy it is
I just love its that it's a purple food
because I get to eat it on this
challenge
I think the fact that I'm also really
hungry probably also make this really
good wrap this in mm-hmm she still
flavor a super strong mm-hmm she's
really good
I've always loved adding black rice to
white rice I kind of like the extra like
texture I'm so satisfied right now I
think I love the color purple even more
now this video is basically there's me
eating for 24 hours so I have dessert oh
my god so I do actually have a purple
dessert even though I don't think
there's gonna be stomach space for it
but maybe in like I don't know two hours
three so was my birthday last week and
two of my friends bought me this amazing
ube cake that I actually already ate
some of you but it's also just like an
actually like really beautiful purple
color this cake is like super vibrant my
gosh it's just gonna fall right over but
this is what it looks like oh it's so
soft get a perfect slice yes okay guys I
gotta let you guys see what this looks
like tada
look at that purple custom cream in the
middle but otherwise I think this is
probably the most purple of purple
desserts
this is a huge bite oh yeah I don't
normally look for obey but uber flavor
and this is like perfect almost like a
coconut a chaste
yes hey so this challenge actually
turned out to be really fun I think
there was definitely more things than I
expected that were actually purple let
me know what color I should try to eat
for 24 hours I'll be here finishing this
cake
[Music]
you